if you picture a warlord's instagram
does it look like this that's ramzan
khadirov
ruthless leader of chechnya and proxy of
russian president vladimir putin
[Music]
here he is nuzzling a deer
these posts entertain millions of
followers
but what they mask is a dark reality
khadirov recently attracted
international criticism when reports
revealed that gay chechens
are being rounded up tortured and killed
by authorities
at a safe house in moscow a chechen
survivor described the brutal
[Music]
broke khadirov spokesperson alvi karamov
denied the reports claiming that there
are no homosexuals in chechnya
you cannot detain and persecute those
who did not exist
given the severity of the allegations
against him it's hard to reconcile the
brutality of khadirov's leadership with
his bizarrely
entertaining online profile
[Music]
where he features animals
celebrities animals
and celebrities and above all
his admiration for vladimir putin
what you don't see is the violence and
regression that have been rampant
under his watch chechnya is one of 21
republics in russia
where regional ethnicities are allowed
semi-autonomous systems of governance
it is a mountainous republic in a mostly
muslim region of russia known as the
north caucasus
in the 1990s chechnya suffered two
devastating wars
the first was fought by separatists who
tried and failed to free chechnya from
russian control following the collapse
of the soviet union
a few years later russia initiated a
second war to eliminate islamist
radicals who they blame for bombings
that killed hundreds of russian
civilians
the war was brutal and putin's forces
destroyed grozny the capital of chechnya
putin later placed ahmad kadyrov
ramzan's father
in charge of rebuilding the republic
ahmad became president of chechnya in
october 2003. but the insurgency
continued and in 2004 khadirov was
killed when islamist separatists found a
parade he was watching in grossen
[Music]
after the bombing ramzan was swiftly
ushered to moscow
where he met putin that same day at the
time
he was leading chechen security forces
and had been blamed for several
kidnappings
but despite the allegations putin
positioned him for leadership and he has
been ruling the republic ever since
2007.
in that time putin has given kadyrov
ample funding in exchange for keeping
the chechen conflict
under control the kremlin funds at least
80
of chechnya's annual budget and ramzan
kadyrov spends that money lavishly
not only on himself but also on
construction projects he constantly
promotes
he often features ahmad khadirov mosque
an opulent building named after his
father that symbolizes both chechen
renewal
and ramzan's self-proclaimed commitment
to islam
he has also used the money to fund an
army of loyalists called the kataropsi
a militia that has roots in the security
forces he ran for his father
on instagram he touts their strength and
discipline offering a clear threat to
possible insurgents
so far his methods have delivered
results khadirov has brought down
islamist violence in chechnya
which has solidified his authority and
served as a major political victory for
putin
part of his strategy has been promoting
a strict interpretation of islam
online he maintains a steady stream of
overtly religious
posts and in public statements he
insists that women wear headscarves and
has supported honor killings as part of
what he calls a virtue campaign
he has also endorsed men shooting women
on the street with paintball guns when
they are not fully covered
like in this youtube video
in addition to shaping his islamic
agenda khadirov uses social media to
craft a warrior persona that is based in
historical notions of chechen identity
it's an identity that can be traced back
to the early 20th century
when leo tolstoy wrote about the chechen
rebellion in his book
hajimarad ever since then ethnic
russians have perceived chechens as
fierce warriors
and that image has played out over the
course of history from the two chechen
wars
to the more recent photos of chechens
fighting for isis
in the middle east now copies of
tolstoy's novel
come with a photo of a modern soldier on
the cover
the tough guy stereotype has also
traveled beyond russia
it is telling that a mobster in the dark
knight is known simply as
the chechen
scrolling through his feed you can see
that khadirov channels that identity
with training montages
[Music]
martial arts clips
[Music]
fitness selfies sport and close
encounters with threatening creatures
but khadirov also poses as the
benevolent leader of chechnya who enjoys
quiet moments with animals
[Music]
bike rides
[Music]
playing with his friends
and performing the les gingka a regional
dance
he also poses as chechnya's biggest
advocate
and has paid for several western
celebrities to visit grozny
past visitors have included the boxer
floyd mayweather
the actor steven seagal
[Music]
and the actress hilary swann honor to
learn more about you and your country
and what you're building who visited for
khadirov's birthday in 2011.
happy birthday mr president apart from
hosting celebrities
khadirov constantly leverages his
relationship with putin to bolster his
authority
[Music]
on instagram he regularly demonstrates
his allegiance to the russian president
but at times his enthusiasm backfires
he once framed a photo of a putin critic
between the crosshairs of a riflescope
a reckless provocation that led some
people to wonder if putin
might be losing control of khadirov
these missteps
do not go unnoticed khadirov's nearly 3
million followers on instagram
are around twice the population of
chechnya some of his posts
have already led to repercussions from
moscow in october
he proudly posted this clip from an mma
5 featuring 10 year old boys
including his own sons in response
russia's ministry of sport launched an
investigation into the event
and later that month anton silanov
putin's finance minister
announced possible cuts to the chechen
budget
now revelations about khadirov's
persecution of gays
have caused global protests and created
fresh tensions
at a recent meeting german chancellor
angela merkel called on putin to
discipline his chechen subordinate
by then putin had already summoned
khadirov to the kremlin for a meeting
but whether this did anything to change
kadyrov's behavior
remains to be seen for the time being
khadirov continues to be putin's man in
chechnya
and as long as he can keep the region
stable things are likely
to stay that way
[Music]
you